let's get straight into your questions
uh now joining me tonight to answer
those questions is doctor deepti good
assani who's a clinical epidemiologist
and senior lecturer at queen mary
university of london william harvey
research institute
next to her we have professor azeem
majid professor of primary care and
public health and head of the department
of primary care and public health at
imperial college london
and then we have
professor robert reed a member of the
joint committee for vaccines and
immunisation and professor of infectious
diseases at the university of uh
southampton thank you very much to all
three of you for being with us tonight
and for answering our audiences
questions at a time when i know we need
as much information as we can get the
first question comes from debbie who's
voicing i think a lot of the covid
fatigue all of us are feeling uh what
will it take to put an end to all these
restrictions and the daily figures and
tests everyone being vaccinated heard
immunity will there ever be an end i'd
like to start with professor robert reed
from the jcvi on that one
well good evening and um
uh well what will put an end to it i i'm
afraid it's time actually uh
this is a highly agile coronavirus
we are expecting it to be with us for
the foreseeable future if
not
perhaps a few years
if not more um what will put an end to
it will be
more and more people having experienced
natural infection and being vaccinated
and as the years roll by we'll probably
see a situation where we're just needing
to
provide booster vaccinations to
certain sectors of the population
particularly the elderly possibly on an
annual basis
but eventually what will put up put an
end to it is is time and um uh i can
foresee a time when uh we'll see the
back of the dangerous aspects of this
this virus just very quickly you say
time any idea of how much time
i wish i knew that uh i wish i knew that
but i'm expecting this to be a recurring
problem for two or three years
okay okay uh dr deichi gerdastani you're
an epidemiologist
we know that the threshold for herd
immunity depends on every disease and
how it's transmitted and obviously we're
still learning about kovid and its uh
and its variants are we closer to
understanding where the level of herd
immunity whether that's through
vaccinations or through having had the
disease uh where that level of herd
immunity might be for covid
so i mean i'm going to first start by
disagreeing with prof reed living with
the virus is a recipe for foreign this
is a virus that's rapidly mutating to
become potentially more transmissible
potentially more severe more able to
escape vaccines and there's no guarantee
that that won't keep on happening in
fact every three to six months you've
seen a new variant uh replace the
previous weight and cause devastating
waves with a lot of deaths and a lot of
long coverage so herd immunity may not
even be possible to reach with this
virus simply because by the time you
have enough you know a particular number
vaccinated or boosted you have a new
vein that arises that escapes previous
immunity really very well in fact in 20
months of this pandemic no country to
date has attained her community and i
think the mistake that i have seen in
terms of public messaging has been that
vaccines are the panacea that will end
this and it is a panacea that will end
this when actually it's layered
mitigations with vaccines being one of
several mitigations that are used over a
period of time and global movement
towards suppressing the virus rather
than living with it which would lead us
out of this
interesting you talk there about
vaccines not being the whole picture of
course restrictions uh lockdowns could
be another part of that picture our
second question uh from uh you at home
is are we locking down to protect those
who have not been vaccinated uh
professor azeem majid i'd like to come
to you on that
um hello uh so so the measures we've
introduced are for the whole population
not just those who are vaccinated
clearly those who might be vaccinated
our greatest risk of illness or
infection and serious illness but
measures protect everyone because um uh
even even those who are vaccinated if
there's high case slumbers approached
some of those people will get infected a
lot of those some will have unfortunate
australian illness that will lead to
ambition hospital or death so these
measures are for everyone and not just
being vaccinated
okay okay uh professor robert reed
there's there's a sort of other question
hidden in that question are we locking
down to protect those who have not been
vaccinated how do we get those people
who have not been vaccinated to get
vaccinated how important is it that they
are vaccinated
oh it's extremely important and i would
uh agree with your other
your other guest
actually the restrictions being imposed
at the moment will protect people who
have been vaccinated because
you know even though i'm a great ex
exponent of vaccines the uh the efficacy
the the protection you get from it is 90
or thereabouts and across the entire
population that means that you're not
going to protect absolutely everybody
with the vaccines there are always going
to be some people who are vulnerable uh
to the infection and to
um disease um so how do we persuade
people who um uh have not come forward
for vaccination and unfortunately there
are still a lot of those people
millions and
all we can do is provide them with the
evidence that vaccines work and are very
safe
we've already shown that this country's
vaccination program has saved many lives
and if you haven't been vaccinated and
you're watching this program if you get
yourself vaccinated now you will reduce
your chances of severe disease
from this infection and you can be sure
that this infection is coming your way
because this is a highly transmittable
virus and we are going to see more
infections in this country very soon so
please go and get vaccinated if you
haven't done so already
okay
a message there for our audience and we
have here a school a school a child
asking uh from our audience saying as a
school chair myself will schools close
again uh now i'm not sure i mean you
know short of asking a government
advisor on that it's very hard for us to
predict that but let's give it a go in
any case professor azeem majid let's
begin with you
do you think it's possible
that schools would close again obviously
you know millions of children worried
about that their education already uh
damaged because of last uh lockdowns
is that something you think might happen
again or do you think everything's being
done to avoid that
um it's possible but something i hope we
can avoid because clay we saw the damage
that was done before by school closures
to children and education so i think
through measures we can mitigate the
infection in skills so ensure that all
staff are vaccinated included with
boosters ensuring we have good air
quality in schools
including good ventilation that we do
test people appropriately when there are
symptoms of infection and we deal with
outbreaks of infection very promptly so
i think through measures like that we
can mitigate the effects of
of the virus in schools and keep schools
open i think closing schools should be a
very very last resort for our society
because the damage that causes i think
facebook has also have a role to play in
schools for older children in particular
so i think through a combination of
measures
we can keep the virus suppressed within
schools and hopefully avoid school
closures but we have unfortunately seen
high case rates in schools in september
when schools reopened uh across
hopefully
sorry to interrupt you that we're going
to stay with uh mark squaring because
our next question uh is should
exemptions have to be proven for
non-mask wearers as too many people are
abusing the exemption excuse
let's start at uh dr deepti go to suny
i'd like to come to you on this i guess
with a question really about first of
all how effective masks are against the
spread of uh kovid and then whether that
would actually warrant this idea of some
sort of punishment for people who are
abusing those non-mask wearing rules
so mask wearing is highly effective but
it depends on how many people are
wearing the mask and the quality of the
mask so we know for example areas that
have had mass mandates and even in
schools where mass wearing has been
present infection rates and outbreaks
have been very low and a high quality
mass like
ffb2ffp3 masks can be very very
protective not just for other people but
also for the wearer
in terms of
penalizing people or asking them for
you know proof of exemptions i don't
think that's necessary i think what you
need is really really good uh public
messaging which i think has been found
really wanting from this government when
the government has conflated mass
squaring with restrictions when mars
actually allow you to be freer because
they reduce the community great and
allow you to move outside and actually
socialize with people in a safer way and
the fact that our own prime minister has
been caught out on many occasions not
wearing masks where our government has
recommended mass squaring itself is poor
role modeling and i think those are the
issues we really really need to fix
before considering penalizing people uh
and asking them to provide proof for
exemptions
okay thank you
a lot of people trying to second-guess
uh the government's plan b and what
they're doing and why they're doing it
this question now is the government
bringing in half-hearted measures uh now
to go over the christmas period with
expected lockdowns to come by the middle
of january so the idea that we uh
we try and have these sort of with small
measures now in order to try and
hopefully get us through christmas and
then we'll see what happens after
christmas because we can go into
lockdown if we need to uh let's start uh
professor azim uh majeed of course i'm
not asking you to try and look into the
government's minds when they're trying
to make these decisions but from a
public health perspective is there an
argument that says actually
protecting christmas protecting people's
mental health health and their
socialization over that christmas period
allowing them to try and have a
semblance over christmas
is very very important and let's see
where that leaves us in january
that is very important i think you know
we're facing a virus that we don't fully
understand um so this new variant is new
and we don't fully understand how it
will uh behave in the next few weeks so
i think hopefully over the next few
weeks we'll have more data on how
effective it is uh how stressed the
infection it is that it causes and how
well it um evades vaccines i think once
that it comes through we can then plan
more effectively for the future so
hopefully we'll have positive news on
those messages i'm very hopeful that
three vaccines will hold the line
against this this variant and if that's
the case we can hopefully have a better
new year as we as we've pushed our
booster program in our population over
the next few weeks
it's interesting because when obviously
the government's looking at data some of
which
we're able to see and some of which were
of course not able to see um
chris whittie showed a graph
recently that was showing
hospitalization
numbers we've had sage recently saying
the omicron based hospital admissions
alone could be in the order of a
thousand per day by the end of this year
uh chris whittie there's showing and you
can see it on your screens there
a graph that shows that the number of
hospitalizations had started to decline
at the beginning of december chris
whittie saying he's expecting that to
start rising again in the next couple uh
of uh weeks as we go into this uh this
omicron uh phase this omicron period um
dr deepti gurdasani do you think
looking at that data that it's
we ought to be getting ahead of this
disease rather than responding to it
once we already see the curve starting
to go up
absolutely and you know hospitalizations
are already going up quite sharply in
the southeast so it's only a matter of
time that they'll be going up everywhere
else as well and actually the sage
documents make this very very clear that
if you act late when hospitalizations
are already high you really have missed
the opportunity because health systems
will very likely get overwhelmed by that
point you have to act early i mean this
is a virus that's doubling every three
days it's causing high levels of
hospitalizations that are doubling more
than doubling how tank province so we
have to learn from that even if we think
that this may be less severe or that
boosters may be effective just the sheer
number of people who get infected could
lead to very very high pressure my
health systems in fact we're talking
about the end of december here but the
sage documents say that the best case
scenario is that they will be between
thousand to 2000 admissions daily in uh
january and they're saying that it could
actually exceed previous speaks so we
need to act aggressively and early and
scale down rather than acting
incrementally as we are right now
professor robert reed i want to get your
thought very very quickly on this
because we do have to move on to the
next question but this is crucial for
christmas where do you stand on the
christmas versus uh covered measures
argument there
well i do think we we need to slow this
virus down um but also we have to have a
sense of proportion
i agree with the government's position i
don't give them advice on on this i give
advice on vaccines
but
what this virus is going to do is is
peak by
late february early march in terms of
infections we simply do not actually
know whether the uk is going to yet
suffer
vastly increased hospitalizations that
information won't start to become
apparent for at least one or two weeks
so it's a little bit early to say um you
see your your what you're asking us to
say is should the government lock down
completely now and that would certainly
stop the variance
transmission very very effectively not
absolutely um but the uh the the
measures that have been taken so far
will contribute uh to slowing it down
and giving our giving us a chance to get
boosters into arms which is going to be
key
okay the next question
the new variant appears to be more
transmissible in view of this shouldn't
the government be preparing the
nightingale uh hospitals uh professor
azeem majid let's start with you on that
should the nightingales be reopened
uh no i don't think so i think we need
to invest our current hospitals in our
current infrastructure so invest in kill
which happens to the community which
will assess patients and perhaps deliver
the new antivirals that are being
promised for the future invest in a e
departments in hospital awards in ic
units in our current hospitals
last year we did invest heavily in in
these hospitals these new hospitals but
they were barely used across the country
so that money really wasn't a very cost
effective use of our taxpayers resources
so i'd rather see the money going to
supporting our current infrastructure
the nhs whether it's in the community or
in our current hospitals rather than
building new hospitals
and there's another part to that
question which is uh essentially saying
you know pointing at the fact that the
omicron variant's supposed to be more
transmissible from what we know about it
thus far
we still don't know how severe
the omicron variant is compared to for
example the delta
variant
dr deepti gurdasani
do you have any more information i know
there's there's uh there's data coming
out of south africa at the moment but
what are your thoughts on that the
severity of those two variants compared
to each other
so the the data coming out of south
africa is very mixed and what it
actually shows is hospitalizations are
doubling or more than doubling every
week but
the severity indices among people
hospitalized and the older age groups
are lower while in the younger age
groups they're higher so overall less
people are for example requiring oxygen
but it's also that a younger cohort is
being hospitalized the part of this
could be that they're younger people
being affected initially because
transmission is usually initially among
young people or that vaccines are having
an effect in the older population as
they should um but what we do know is
that it is spreading really really
quickly and ultimately if you look at
population impact even if this rate is
less severe than delta the rate of rise
in the sheer number of people impacted
will overwhelm health care systems
regardless of the severity and that's
what sage modeling is also telling us so
it's very very important to actually
prevent people getting to hospitals by
preventing them getting infected
because you know hospital capacity is
finite and can only be increased so much
given the limited staff that we have and
that our health care forces already
devastated so prevention is vitally
important for a very very rapidly
spreading virus such as this okay thank
you uh the next question if i have a
positive pcr how do i know which variant
i am positive uh for so this is into the
pcr tests and how how specific they can
be about the different variants uh let's
start professor robert reed where are we
at with that how long would it take for
every pcr to be screened for which
variant it is
um i'm not sure whether the public are
yet given the information about whether
they've got what's called an s gene pro
dropout but um
i can tell you we're not if we i i can
tell you we're not cause i had a pcr on
monday uh which was negative um and uh
and i was uh at the time when i was
asking there they said no they're not
telling us on the nhs they're not yet
telling which strain we would have yeah
yes i mean it goes to a central lab and
it's verified and the information is is
used by epidemiologists which is
critically important for the general
public actually i'm not sure that it
makes any difference at all whether
you're infected with delta or omicron
because as far as we know at the moment
although omicron is almost certainly
more transmissible uh there's no
evidence that it causes more severe or
more or less severe disease even so
actually for for members of the public
it's not a relevant question once you're
infected with kobe
covert 19 uh that's that's the
information you need so um so i'm not
sure the question is pertinent
okay
i guess i wonder if the first that you
would hear of of having omicron if you
did have it was the follow-up phone
calls that might happen if you did have
it versus the delta because they're
obviously tracking uh omicron in a way
that they're not delta um as a follow-up
to uh that question vaccine uh efficacy
on omicron we know that that it vaccine
efficacy on omron is still making people
less severely ill if they do catch uh
omicron
do we have any sense of how vaccines are
faring compared to you know omicron
compared to delta how much they'll fight
uh those two variants professor reed
um we don't have confirmed information
yet it's still a little bit early the
really important thing uh aside from
laboratory information is the clinical
epidemiology
the laboratory information is not yet
complete
we should know fairly soon uh whether or
not uh the uh the the blood of
vaccinated people is highly effective
against omicron or not
and if there is a reduction in effects
in efficacy in in neutralization
capacity uh just how much that reduction
is because when we know that we will
have an opportunity to uh make firmer
predictions
um so um we won't really know about um
whether um uh the current vaccine uh
program has blunted likelihood of
omicron disease
for
one or two weeks so uh uh it's still a
little bit early let's say okay uh
professor azeem majid do you have any
thoughts on uh that idea of of pcrs how
do i know which variant i've tested
positive for
as people tell normally what what uh
type they have if they are infected
you're told if it's positive a liquid
your test results uh currently most um
infections are due to delta so if you
are infected it's probably delta
although that could change in coming
weeks if the omicron increases uh still
further uh but i i agree with pressure
read that people need to know they're
positive or negative the actual variant
doesn't really matter that much uh
because
it doesn't really affect your clinical
management what variant you've got at
the moment
okay uh right our final question taking
the latest government rules uh into uh
account on theater and cinemas why is it
deemed safer to go into a packed pub or
a restaurant than a theater uh or a
cinema let's uh start with dr deepti
gurdasani on that does the virus
care whether you're in a theater or a
cinema or a pub or a restaurant is there
any logic to that do you think
no i mean you'd have to ask government
that question because the virus is
airborne and hair bones have spread
happens in all
particularly indoor crowded environments
where people gather and those are
exactly where super spreading happens so
i think any scientists or physicists
would struggle to explain government
policy in that regard
okay uh uh professor azeem presumably
part of the thinking there is that you
have to take your mask off if you're in
a pub or a restaurant to drink and eat
therefore if it's going to be off it
might as well be off the whole time
whereas in a theater or a cinema it's
much more feasible to carry on doing
that activity with the mask on
that's correct and a pub tell you you
can't be the mask on all the time
because you have to eat and drink
um so either you close pubs or allow
people to take their mouths off
but is the case that pubs are
potentially quite risky environments um
because people are crowded together
closely uh off the ventilation is quite
poor they're talking loudly so expelling
more air and more virus
some advice is if you are vulnerable
clinically to perhaps avoid pubs in the
next few weeks until we know more about
this variant and how it's um how it
spreads
okay that's very interesting that yeah
that you're saying potentially might be
worth thinking about avoiding uh pubs
there because i'm sure lots of people
watching will want uh that sort of
advice very finely in a it really really
quickly professor robert reed just for
the final word on this uh do you think
when we look at the way that uh the
advice has gone uh the fact that working
from home is suggested but you know you
can carry on going to quite a lot of
social gatherings do you think the
government
is prioritizing our mental health in
this period over perhaps uh a sensible
approach to to try to contain the virus
and is that important
it absolutely is important i i think the
government is taking all sorts of advice
from all sorts of places and it's trying
to balance um uh the the need to reduce
as much as possible the rate of progress
of this virus through our population
with their mental health and with the
economy and with people's wider health
so um i i think it's an extremely
complex uh problem to which there's no
simple answer all right well thank you
very much i'm not sure that's cleared it
up for us uh but uh certainly uh thank
you so much to our panel here tonight
professor robert reed from the jcvi uh
next to him professor azeem majid
professor of primary care and public
health and dr deepti gurdasani who's a
clinical epidemiologist thank you to you
all for answering those questions